E
KINDS OF STAKES.
>> Jesse: TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT JOINS ME NOW.
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY TO
RADDATZ?
>> LISTEN, IT'S JUST CRAZY TO
SUGGEST ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, IT REALLY IS
TELLING, JESSE, BECAUSE IT SHOWS
THAT THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THEY
ARE REALLY CLUELESS, ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE BORDER AS
WELL AS JOE BIDEN'S SPOKESPERSON
WHO SAID THAT THE BORDER IS NOT
OPEN.
WE CAN PROVE THIS FACTUALLY WITH
THIS VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
INFORMATION.
AND THAT IT WAS JUST TWO AND A
HALF YEARS AGO WHEN WE HAD THE
MOST SECURE BORDER IN DECADES
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP DOING FOUR
THINGS.
REMAIN IN MEXICO, TITLE 42, END
CATCH AND RELEASE AND BUILD THE
BORDER WALL.
THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID.
AND WE HAD THE LOWEST BORDER
CROSSINGS SINCE LAST CENTURY.
NOW, UNDER JOE BIDEN, WE HAVE
FAR MORE RECORD-SETTING NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER THAN EVER BEFORE.
THIS ALL BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN'S
POLICIES.
>> DID YOU WANT TO FLY RADDATZ
UP IN THE AIR IN THAT LITTLE
HELICOPTER BEHIND YOU GUYS AND
SHOW HER WHAT WAS ACTUALLY GOING
DOWN?
>> JESSE, WE DID.
RIGHT AFTER THAT INTERVIEW,
SHORTLY AFTER THAT QUESTION, WE
DID FLY HER UP IN THE A
HELICOPTER, AND SHOWED HER
EXACTLY WHAT WAS GOING ON ON THE
GROUND.
AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
PEOPLE ARE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
JOE BIDEN IS DOING NOTHING ABOUT
IT.
THAT'S WHY TEXAS IS HAVING TO
STEP UP AND TAKE EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORTS THAT HAVE NEVER BEEN
UNDERTAKEN BY ANY STATE IN THE
HISTORY IN THE UNITED STATES TO
TRY TO SECURE OUR BORDER.
>> Jesse: RIGHT NOW LOOKING AT
IMAGES OF DONENS AND DOZENS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS SLEEPING IN
SLEEPING BAGS, PILLOWS,
COMFORTERS, IN THE EL PASO
AIRPORT.
HAVE YOU SEEN THIS?
>> AND SO, JESSE, THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE I'M ABOUT TO TELL
YOU, THAT IS ONE ASPECT ABOUT
ALL THOSE PEOPLE THAT YOU SEE
SLEEPING THERE, AS YOU WERE KIND
OF ALLUDING TO IN YOUR
COMMENTARY EARLIER, THEY HAVE
ALREADY BEEN GIVEN A PIECE OF
PAPER AUTHORIZING THEM TO BE
THERE IN THAT AIRPORT OR IN THE
UNITED STATES.
SO, THEY GOT THE FREE PASS ONCE
THEY GOT TO A BORDER PATROL
AGENT WHO GAVE THEM THAT PASS.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, IS THIS ONE
OF THESE THINGS LIKE OH GO FIND
AN ICE CENTER IN A YEAR AND I
WILL SEE YOU NEVER?
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
ARE YOU GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SEND ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THROUGH
BUS OR PLANE TO CITIES IN THE
NORTHEAST?
>> SO, JESSE, LET ME TELL YOU
HOW IT WORKS.
THAT IS THE FIRST THING WE TRY
TO DO IS SEND PEOPLE BACK OR TO
RETURN THEM OR REPEL THEM.
THAT'S OUR FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE.
THE SECOND LINE OF DEFENSE IS TO
ARREST THEM.
BUT THE CARTELS KNOW THIS.
THE REASON WHY YOU SEE PEOPLE
STREAMING ACROSS THE BORDER IN
SINGLE FILE GOING TO A
PARTICULAR LOCATION IS BECAUSE
THE CARTELS KNOW TO TAKE THEM TO
THAT LOCATION BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ON THAT
LOCATION AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL CONTROL AND
PROCESS THESE PEOPLE, GIVE THEM
THEIR PAPERWORK AND SET THEM
FREE.
IT'S THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE SET
FREE THAT WE PUT ON BUSES AND
SEND TO SANCTUARY CITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND, YES, MORE ARE
EN ROUTE TONIGHT AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SEND THEM.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
WELL, ASPEN IS A GREAT PLACE
THIS TIME OF YEAR TORE ANYBODY